carette pour menu du jour carottes cake
cookies terry belton partage son amour
de la cuisine à ces quatre apprentis
mais pas seulement
la new-yorkaise à travers cette activité
permet aussi aux enfants d'apprendre
l'anglais comme il ya beaucoup de
mouvements sont là c'est assez passive
même si on est loin du temps parce que
j'ai même des élèves de trois 3 ans
d'être le tunnel qui viennent donc je
m'adapte pour chaque niveau chaque
personnalité du sport c'est pour
s'amuser en anglais mais on l'apprend
des vocabulaires après avoir fait les
recettes
ils vont lire les recettes et je vais
corriger le plus nos créations
cela fait sept ans qu'elle donne ses
cours il y a bien évidemment le repas
mais durant la confection le professeur
d'anglais prend vraiment le temps de
reprendre les élèves sur les intonations
ou encore les pousse à améliorer leur
vocabulaire
une pratique qui plaît à ses étudiants
c'est la première fois que je viens
parce que j'ai des amis qui font de
l'anglais ici j'aime beaucoup l'anglais
et j'aime aussi beaucoup cuisiner c'est
pour ça que j'ai bien voulu venir ici ça
fait plaisir
je suis nul en anglais et parlé est
comme ça on apprend ludiquement et on
s'ennuie pas si vous souhaitez
participer sachez que le cours d'anglais
et de cuisine sont à 30 euros et à la
fin de chaque cours une petite
récompense vous attend